how do we get your products into stores
it's a question I get asked a lot by
entrepreneurs we have a physical product
they're trying to get into the store
they're struggling they think you know I
have this great product I can produce it
in mass quantities if only it was in
Walmart or only was in Target or
whatever store I'd make millions the
problem here is these guys are getting
pitched all the time by entrepreneurs
who think they have a great product and
you have to really stand out right there
are buyers for every category so
whatever category you fall into their
buyers for it and you can pitch them you
can email them you can call them you can
if they have demo days you can go and
meet them but you need to have something
that makes you stand out against
everybody else was pitching because
everybody wants to be on those shelves
in those stores so what are you going to
do that's so different the biggest thing
you can do is get some momentum and this
is what I saw when I was in the VC world
people were pitching me ideas for their
business plan most people come with just
an idea with no momentum no product no
demo just an idea on paper the closer
you are to actually having customers
having some kind of revenue showing some
kind of momentum with your business the
better chance you have of getting
success with whoever you're selling an
investor a store any custom your big
order you're trying to get you want to
show momentum nobody wants to be the
first person to take this huge risk on
you I've got a question from a reader
manu who has a product called health
balls
so it says similar to health bars that
manu makes it says producing in large
quantities none of it not a problem I
want to get on the stores and shelves
and stores made of nine ingredients no
sugar added on going the problem here is
ok the health food category is super
saturated it's a growing market it's
trending but there's so many companies
who are trying to get into this space
the key thing here is you need to get
momentum you need to get customers on
your own you need to get people who are
ordering from your website you need to
get people following you on social media
people who are following your Twitter
account and YouTube and Facebook and
they're engaging with you and when you
say I'm gonna be here people will come
you need to build that up companies
expect that
now if you just go with an idea or even
a finished product they're not gonna buy
from you you need to show that if I come
and I bring my product to you I'm also
going to bring a market to you that
dramatically increases the chance of you
getting the deal you're after for
example is I'm doing a book deal right
now okay I'm writing the book I'm in the
process of it I could go to any
publisher and get a book deal if I was
willing just to write a book and get a
cut of the Commission's I could do that
with any publisher because I have an
audience I built that up it's taking me
a while but I built that up now I want a
good book deal I want to work with a
publisher who's going to really promote
this thing I want a good advance up
front so I get commitment out of them oh
I can pick and choose where most people
would be begging to get a book deal
where most people would do it and would
pay to do it but I have a leverage on
these companies I stand out from
everybody else that I'm going up against
I'm attractive to them because I've
built up a lot of momentum on my own and
that's what you need to do so before
going out and pitching these guys and
being thrown into the average category
with everybody else build up some
momentum get some customers get some
traction get some traffic get some media
mentions and when you go and you pitch
them you can say I've been in this
newspaper I have these customers ongoing
I have these advisors on my team I have
this many followers on my social media
accounts who are loyal fans when I go
somewhere people come out to the events
right build that up so then when you go
and pitch them you're gonna be so
different then everybody else is
pitching that the companies will fight
over having you on board right when I'm
lining up my book deal I'll have
publishers fight over who gets my book
because of the audience and attraction I
built up and you want the same thing for
you you want to be in a position of
power position of leverage and even
though you need them right I still need
the book publisher to publish this thing
you still need the stores to sell your
stuff or you can create leverage by
having a differentiating factor and
showing some momentum
believe fazil so you're watching like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it makes gonna do more and I'd
love to hear from you leave a comment
underneath let me know what you're
thinking you have a question of it below
like a video response thank you so much
and I'll see you soon